hey everyone my name is Jordan wat and
I'm a designer with plants vs zombies
garden warfare 2 today I'm very excited
to tell you more about solo play in
addition to traditional 4 player co-op
our solo play mode lets you play by
yourself with a team of up to three AI
control teammates in garden ops your
mission is simple protect the garden
against the zombies for this solo round
I'm choosing pops corn electro citron
druid rose and vampire flower when going
it alone the big difference is hot
swapping pressing up or down on the
d-pad allows you to switch between all
of your AI control teammates at any time
during the match let's meet the squad
this is pops cork pops nifty corn
cracker has an enhanced zoom making for
more accurate firing from the distance
this is electro citron he's from the
future electro citron electro charger
attack arts from one enemy to the next
you can also hold down the trigger to
charge up for more massive damage in
some instances it might be a good idea
to swap to a character like Rose who has
excellent crowd control talents like her
ability to cast a zombie freezing time
bubble and let's not forget cheater
zombies into goats then there's vampire
flower her life leachability steals help
from enemies and adds it to her own hot
swapping also lets you earn XP for all
four of your characters during gameplay
all you have to do is hot swap to that
character and you'll earn XP while
you're playing as that character you'll
also earn coins which can go towards
sticker packs to unlock even more sweet
goodies this is a boss lots wave
we've added brand new bosses to garden
warfare 2 so today say it loud namaste
to the Zen sensei he's small but don't
be fooled because he packs a heck of a
punch Zen sensei can use his empowers to
clone himself turning this one-man army
into wealth in actual army finally a new
feature we've added to garden warfare 2
is crazy settings which we can check out
in our fan favorite 24 player fight fest
gardens and graveyards it lets you
change up the game and a bunch of really
wild ways like giving the match
low-gravity infinite ammo explode on
vanquish a knock-back mode super speed
and ridiculously low health for instant
vanquishes for now i'll choose speed
boost craziness and low gravity but
remember that when you play you can
choose a switch on any of the settings
or even all of them thanks for watching
and keep an eye out for more dev Diaries
to come